dude I was facetiming with Tariq on the
plane I was facetiming and you know what
you're about to take off but people are
getting on the plane it's kind of quiet
and I go I'm on a plane and he goes you
are you guys super live he goes show me
your dick and literally know everybody
around me turn and this do two started
laughs you're standing he just started
[ __ ] die like a dude what the [ __ ]
and then they always nothing goes I want
to see your dad cause I got we went
shooting my dad should he's got himself
a little thousand dollar Brennan [ __ ]
Labor Day you don't say loads videos
Labor Day don't my dad went further your
follows man it's my other problem don't
see that well I was oh you weren't doing
anything in that sexual time man you go
load so make me get razor Brown out oh
my god all right I shot a couple guns
I'm gonna go through it shotguns now my
dad's got a three thousand dollar
handmade 1911
that's a 45 trigger fingers made in 1911
well it's the same design it's 1911 it's
a handmade gun do you you spend a
minimum three grand on that gun okay
keeps it in a case he keeps in a little
bag he brings it with him we go to the
shooting range
I gotta rent my guns I got myself a
Springfield don't worry what that is
then I shot myself an assault rifle on a
cave no I'm sorry an ar-15 oh do not
automatic but it was a semi-automatic
ar-15s assault right yeah well you can
put it on burst well don't do that don't
don't do that but whose it's it was out
you put it on first if it's if it's
military issue this is not an issue
see I only shoot military well I can you
know what they call me when I shoot do
you know what they call me and this is
for all cockeyed down they go like this
they go when I shoot they go a bro hey
got guy nope no targets over here it's
for a gallon I shoot over here she were
both eyes open and then the head guy
goes nah that's the dig divers shoot
whatever you want bro I shoot with both
eyes open I'm left-eye dominant you even
know what that means now yeah hold on
hold on for a sec so you shoot like this
hey
when you see me shoot like this yeah of
course you do because your amateur when
they see me shoot they go like this they
go dude what's it like at the bottom of
the ocean I go wow they go dude what's
it like to eat fish in one gulp I'm like
what are you talking about and they go
we're obviously a grouper I go what do
you mean you know we group you you you
could you shoot tight groups you mind if
we call you the the grouper a grouper I
feel like there's a better name for that
I wouldn't want definitely in my group
because you made it
I grew up group Maddon when I said that
to my dad driving away I haven't seen
him in Hoyt in my 50 years I've never
seen him more normally he was like what
you say I go call me the group but from
now on I group them up he goes yeah 25
feet oh yeah what are you talking about
group is there any truth you and you and
Tito really trying to do this damn thing
again god I hope so man I I don't know I
come on if you're me I was so I was so I
hated that that match was over and I
know what you said about you go hey come
on that one's over you got to let it go
Brennan I don't let anything go there's
no reason to let anything go man we've
only got so much time to compete go get
the matches that you want I'm not
backing off and I'll do it five more
times and I gotta imagine he looks at me
and goes dude you suck I think getting
Tito to the table would be a little bit
easy I'm already there and I got to
think of your Tina when you [ __ ] me out
in two minutes you you sign up for that
one again so let's see what happens
there but yeah I think there's a little
bit of legs to it you still want to
fight you still want to fight and belt
or two I'll see you how your showing
with Wanderlei which I worked and you
look great man I appreciate that buddy I
had I had a great experience that night
fun trip all the way around going out
there to the garden and doing it and I'm
looking forward to what's been mix for
family and I speculate for you I think
they're gonna put Vandal and phaidor
together which it's fun from the pride
days and I realize it's not the same way
but somebody's guaranteed to fall down
in that one I like it i ballot tours got
some some good cards to play right now
let's see what they decide to do with
the chips I wouldn't be mad at a jail
phaidor fight yeah that you know they
were talking about that too and then I
had some major legs to Chuck Liddell I
really thought that
gonna happen and chucks in the gym he's
trained and he's had meetings with
kocher Chuck haha like Chuck Liddell
first rate or down no versus me I don't
like it Chuck and then that lost a
little bit of steam - Chuck still a gym
trained and he's had the meetings but he
hasn't signed the paper and it's like
Chuck I can't wait around you know wait
I want to I want to compete yeah no
one's getting younger that's the best
Joker but he won't do it no no I really
like ice to the room with it in a
depressing way he does this laughs and I
had him do it in front of all like our
friends yeah he was like a Gil night
like mid running charades like it's a
running charades lemonade and I swear to
God I believe this it was everybody's
like hook anyway he goes I just heard
you go dead sighs anyway because it's
full commitment to four Dark Knight
comes out and the posters out people are
seeing the Heath Ledger make Olivia and
and like we're just shooting the [ __ ] at
Brian's house and we're like how do you
think he got the scars and I'd like I'll
tell you exactly oh my god I caught it
he's like he lost a bet he's like a bet
and he and he's like we're gonna kill
you or whatever and he goes no no please
please and they like murder his wife in
front of him he takes them they go like
now you kill yourself you know you can
cut your know and it hurts from
hysterical sobbing and crying into
maniacal laughter and so I was all doing
in front of okay all right I'll do all
do like 80% of okay
[Laughter]
[Laughter]
okay so should we switch running
charades nude he did that another
[ __ ] 50% yeah and the whole room
after he kills in the whole room no
rooms all how good is that dumb like so
much like most of our like oh there's a
new Batman movie like what hair your
reaction at that you go that all that
here and your eyes are bloodshot you go
well it was different with it was
different I know I forgot a line you're
up Janine you stupid [ __ ]
you guys need to know I was 18 years old
in 80 days with my girl no it was with
my girl and there was a Clydesdale horse
they were Clydesdale horses large horse
behind a what what I guess the kind of
electric fence that keeps a Clydesdale
from jumping it it's a dinosaur
yeah why you'd want to keep quiet I
guess they're a bus to a fence anyway I
said to my girl I'm gonna touch that she
goes don't
how were you 18 make sense I was like
yeah right you trying to I check this
way with my mortality I go do it cuz man
and you're trying to impress her hmm
caveman stop man me Rock bash there you
go me let you touch we're drunk we I had
some Paul my song wine we had a little
picnic and try rock hard sure was
probably wasn't any more because I work
my magic on her oh yeah and by magic
when you lay down that ajik when I met
in exile yeah I want to grow a take her
clothes off I beg don't move I - yeah
too late like like talk about a prison
it's out mayonnaise I was a premature
ejaculator all the way through my
twenties dad not me dude never I mean
through my 20 never too late
really
I don't think I was able to really bear
down until I was probably 25 26 oh well
yeah maybe even later turn around so you
touch the fence yeah touch the fence but
I did it I did a slice right through
where I went did like that like chin
touch in the dinner table [ __ ] it hurts
so bad my finger like like like I get it
yeah the only sound to make if you ever
sound brother Big Daddy
hey like it was so not sexy either oh my
gosh what a girl thing they he was the
worst
it was the [ __ ] I can't imagine pissing
on that